good organizations have balance you know
there's two captains two leaders well
they're not equal oh that's the problem
they're not equal there has to be a bias
so I talked about will and resources
mm-hmm right so one leader you know is
more the visionary more responsible for
the inspiration the will of the people
right and one is more responsible for
the resources ensuring that we're we're
getting the results getting results your
CEO or CFO you know it's your operator
mm-hmm and but they can't they're not
equal because there will always be
circumstances big and small that that
one will have to be sacrificed in order
to advance the other necessarily and the
question is where's the bias and there
must be a bias towards will over
resources and when I talk about putting
people before profit you know people get
all worried that I'm think that profits
unimportant no there has to be a biased
even if it's 5149 you know there has to
be a bias and and the the the will has
to be prioritized the vision has to come
first because so if you have two
captains one is taking care of the team
of the people and the other one of the
results you say the manager or the
leader who's taking care of the team
should be the vision the vision the
vision yeah the just cause which is
usually the people person but not always
but but but it's it's the person who's
looking to advance the thing needs the
operator because I can see the far-off
distant future but I can't see the rocks
and the trees to get me there
and so I need somebody who's focused
with their head down the operator to
make sure that we can make the
short-term steps we need to make -
that's the greater good but I need there
has to be someone navigating yes but
there needs to be like a hierarchy there
has to be a hierarchy correct and then
the but it is a partnership it is a team
and the best CEO is the best CFOs that
I've ever met they have this amazing
humility where they don't want to be the
CEO but rather they say I'm really good
at what I do but it inspires me to help
advance that because if you put an
operator without a vision in the
visionary position then all they're
gonna do is run the company by the
numbers yeah and the company will at
some point stop
because a finite mindset has a finite
lifespan yeah
[Music]